hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live es gibt nicht mehr viele
Staatschefs und regierungschefinnen im
Westen die noch mit dem russischen
Präsidenten sprechen die Türkei das Land
zwischen West und Ost hält sich auch im
Verhältnis zu Putin gerne in der Mitte
und so hat sich der türkische Präsident
der receptah heb Erdogan heute im
russischen Sotschi zu Gesprächen mit
russlands Präsident Vladimir Putin
getroffen erdogan will sich als
Vermittler zurückmelden Putin zurück
Rückkehr zu einem getreideabkommen
überreden das Moskau im Juli
aufgekündigt hatte und seitdem auch
wieder ukrainische Häfen angreift wir
sehen das hier so erneut Geschehen
gestern nah Odessa das zeigen uns diese
Fotos Erdogan trägt aber die westlichen
Sanktionen gegen Russland nicht mit ein
Spagat den Erdogan dafür sucht am
liebsten will er eben mit Russland und
mit dem besten Geschäfte machen deshalb
ist das Thema heute bei uns Erdogans
macht Poker mit Putin und ihr könnt
gerne Fragen stellen natürlich wie immer
direkt per Mail oder im Stream
kommentiert mit und wir haben jetzt
gleich direkt am Anfang eine
Live-Schalte zu unseren beiden Armin
Körper ist für uns in Moskau Jörg
Brasilien Istanbul hallo schön dass Ihr
da seid ihr beiden
hallo
Armin seit Oktober haben sich diese
beiden Staatschefs nicht mehr persönlich
gesehen zuletzt war das Verhältnis
angespannt weil Erdogan eben auch Deals
mit Kiew macht heute also kein neuer
Getreide Deal der abgeschlossen wurde
das ist die News wie ist die Stimmung
zwischen den beiden gibt's da noch
Chancen für einen Deal
ung
ein bisschen darauf schauen worüber in
der Pressekonferenz nicht gesprochen
wurde also es wurde praktisch nicht oder
sehr wenig über Syrien gesprochen und
die beiden ja unterschiedliche Parteien
unterstützen es wurde gar nicht darüber
gesprochen dass die Türkei ja auch
Waffen liefert an die Ukraine dass die
Türkei der Ukraine eine NATO
Mitgliedschaft in Aussicht gestellt hat
dass man den Moskau gar nicht gerne
gehört hat und das Präsident selenski
bei seinem letzten Besuch in Ankara fünf
fünf ukrainische Kriegsgefangenen mit
heim genommen hat die von den Russland
glaubte dass sie bis zum Ende der
Kampfhandlungen der Türkei bleiben also
all die Themen wurden nicht angesprochen
und das heißt das schon ernsthaft darum
ging ein Ergebnis zu finden
und Jörg die Frage an dich warum wäre
Erdogan so ein Deal aber eben wichtig
oder um was geht es ihm da sonst noch
also es geht ihm natürlich wir haben es
gehört um um den Deal aus
wirtschaftlichen Gründen auch aus
sicherheitspolitischen Gründen aber es
geht ihm auch darum dem heimischen
Publikum zu zeigen wie wichtig die
Türkei jetzt als Spieler auf der
Weltbühne ist wenn man die türkischen
Medien sich heute angesehen oder
angehört hat dann sprechen die nicht von
einer Niederlage oder von einem
schlechten Verhandlungsergebnis sondern
sie Preisen im Prinzip weiter die Rolle
Erdogans als Letzter Direktor Vermittler
zwischen dem Westen und zwischen
Präsident Putin heben noch mal vor dass
er es ja war der jetzt die Vorschläge
der Vereinten Nationen in Moskau
vorgelegt hat und entsprechend auch
weiter der Vermittler bleiben wird also
diese diplomatische Rolle diese Rolle
auf der Weltbühne die ist Erdogan
offensichtlich seit sehr wichtig aber
das ist natürlich nicht nur der einzige
Grund er hat schon massive
wirtschaftliche aber auch Sicherheit
sind Interessen bei diesem Getreide
Abkommen
und zurückgespielt noch mal die Frage
nach Moskau Armin warum ist der
türkische Präsident für im Zweifel eben
auch den russischen Präsidenten für
Putin wichtig
besonders
spricht mit beiden Seiten ist da der
einzige aus dem Kreis der NATO-Staaten
er macht mit beiden Seiten Geschäfte das
ist natürlich was was auch gut in
wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen
beeindruckt man muss ja auch sehen die
beiden sind ja sind ja Urgesteine der
Weltpolitik als Dienstamt kam da hieß
der amerikanische Präsident George und
der deutsche Bundeskanzler Schröder also
die haben schon die verbindet viel und
für Putin ist es natürlich hoch
interessant mit der Türkei gerade
Energie die jetzt zu machen sein Garten
dahin zu verkaufen weil die Türkei ja
eben die Sanktion des Westens nicht
mitträgt
und zum Schluss noch eine Frage nach
Istanbul an Dich Jörg Erdogan der hatte
nach der Kündigung dieses Abkommens
gewarnt hatte gesagt sollte sich der
Krieg auf das Schwarze Meer ausweiten
werde dies Zitat eine Katastrophe für
unsere Region sein Erdogan braucht
nämlich Frieden im Schwarzen Meer für
die Gaslieferungen aus Russland unter
anderem wie abhängig ist denn da die
Türkei oder ist der Einfluss der Türkei
schon auch groß genug um sich jetzt
nicht unbedingt nur als den Abhängigen
zu sehen
also ich glaube schon dass es in der Tat
so ist dass es gegenseitige
Abhängigkeiten sind wir haben es hier
gehört russland hat natürlich ein
Interesse daran dass die Türkei das
Präsident Erdogan mit dem Westen
vermittelt russland will Gas an die
Türkei verkaufen russland will dass die
Türkei zum großen Verteilzentrum für
russisches Gas nach Europa wird russland
will noch weitere Atomkraftwerke in der
Türkei bauen da gibt es also durchaus
Interesse und auf türkischer Seite sind
die ähnlich groß die Türkei hat z.B
große Schulden in Russland was die
Gaslieferungen angeht dadurch dass die
Türkei eben auch sich nicht an den
westlichen Sanktionen beteiligt ist sie
für Russland eben auch so das Tor in die
Welt russische Touristen sind
mittlerweile die größte Kundengruppe
hier an der türkischen Ägäis also die
Abhängigkeiten die sind gegenseitig und
insofern wird Präsident Erdogan
natürlich auch versuchen dieses Pfund
jetzt aber mit diesem Pfund zu wuchern
und
irgendwie zu versuchen diesen Deal jetzt
doch noch zu retten der für ihn für
seine Wirtschaft aber auch für die
Sicherheit Interesse der Türkei im
Schwarzen Meer sehr sehr wichtig ist
danke für die Einschätzung aus Istanbul
und Moskau danke Anja Brase und Armin
Körper
in wie vielen Bereichen Türkei und
Russland miteinander verbunden sind
Geschäfte machen und was das Verhältnis
zuletzt getrübt hat dazu jetzt zunächst
einen Beitrag von Thomas Gonsior und
Luca Simonis
Auge in Auge mit Putin für westliche
Spitzenpolitiker seit Russlands
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
ausgeschlossen für ihn nicht der
türkische Präsident Erdogan traf sich
schon mehrfach mit Moskaus Machthaber
was sie verbindet gemeinsame Interessen
politische und vor allem wirtschaftliche
an westlichen Sanktionen gegen Russland
beteiligt sich die Türkei nicht Ankara
liefert etwa Maschinen nach Moskau und
drohnenteile
umgekehrt schickt Russland Gas über die
2020 in Betrieb genommene Pipeline Jerks
Stream die Türkei dient als
verteilstation
russische Firmen bauen außerdem am
Mittelmeer das erste türkische
Atomkraftwerk
und Urlaub in der Türkei das ist auch
Russen erlaubt sie sowie Geschäftsleute
dürfen einreisen
allerdings es gab und gibt Differenzen
Grund
Erdogan hält Kontakte zur Ukraine hält
sich die Türen zum Westen offen so
verkaufen private türkische Firmen
fertige Drohnen an die Ukraine
Ankara ließ im Juli zu dem ukrainische
Kriegsgefangener nach Hause mit Moskau
war aber vereinbart dass sie erst nach
Kriegsende gehen dürfen und die Türkei
gab ihre Blockade gegen den
NATO-Beitritt Schwedens auf Erdogan
bescherte Putin so eine schwere
politische Niederlage
dennoch der türkische Machthaber sieht
sich als Vermittler ein doppeltes Spiel
auch heute wieder für den Westen
jedenfalls ist es wohl beides zugleich
Risiko und Chance
[Musik]
zur Einordnung für eure Fragen haben wir
uns jetzt eine Expertin eingeladen Daria
iserschenko ist bei mir vom Zentrum für
angewandte Türkei Studien von der
Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik sie
beschäftigt sich ganz intensiv mit den
Beziehungen von Türkei und Russland
schön dass Sie bei uns sind hallo
guten Abend eben gerade in dem Beitrag
viel gehört was ist da eben für
Abhängigkeiten gibt die erste Frage
zunächst an sie wer braucht da wen mehr
also ist die ist Russland für die Türkei
wichtiger oder umgekehrt
das ist tatsächlich eine ewige Frage in
diesem Beziehung wer hat das sagen aber
das Verhältnis zwischen der Türkei und
Russland ist in der Tat so vielfältig
so dass es gegenseitige Abhängigkeit
gibt und zwar auf mehreren Ebenen und
das ist tatsächlich nicht so leicht
durchzuschauen wer braucht war wenn mehr
vielleicht lohnt es sich auch so ein
Gesamtblick noch mal so liefern oder
diese Beziehung erstmal gibt es eine
bilateralien Ebene und das sprechen wir
vom Handel Tourismus Energie Sektor wird
zu nehmen wichtig denn so günstige
gastlieferungen und auch Bau von
Atomkraftwerken zweitens und das ist
durch diese auch sehr wichtig und
vielleicht auch unterschätzt wird ist
dieses ähm
das regionale Konfliktmanagement was
was Ankara und Moskau seit 2016
etabliert haben und zwar sehen wir diese
Zusammenarbeit in Syrien Libyen
und jetzt auch in der Ukraine im
Schwarzmeer
Raum und drittens gibt es auch so der
Faktor besten und da würde ich sagen
Ankara braucht Moskau mehr in was so
Erdogan in deiner Strategie der
alternativen sprich was Ankara von
Westen nicht bekommt bekommt man von
Moskau Beispiel Kauf von russischen
Luftabwehrsystem und das ist natürlich
ein Mehrwert für Moskau sonst gerade
gesagt Ankara braucht Moskau mehr wir
haben heute gelernt es gibt vor allem
jetzt erstmal auch keinen Deal in diesem
getreideabkommen da gab es also jetzt
keine positive Meldung für Ankara es
gibt eine User Frage von Emre fragt sich
wie groß ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass
Erdogan sich verzockt bei diesem Poker
denkt ihr dass Erdogan sich bald für
eine Seite entscheiden muss bzw dazu
gedrängt wird was glauben sie
nee ich denke so lange wir von einer
direkten militärische Konfrontation
zwischen NATO und Russland nicht
sprechen dann kann Ankara weiter
valentieren ich würde vielleicht nur ein
Tieren auch meiner
vorherige Aussage wer braucht man mehr
das kann man eben nicht so leicht sagen
weil eben diese gelaterale Ebene der hat
ein Fluss auf das regionale und
umgekehrt Beispiel jetzt sprechen wir
von Getreide dir und der Tatsache das
war Erdogan der nach solche gereist ist
und nicht putzen der nach Istanbul oder
andere gekommen ist das würde schon
dafür sprechen dass er Erdogan diese
dieses Getreide die mehr braucht als
Russland das hat zum Beispiel guten
heute auch so irgendwie und auffällig
betont dass er dort an dieser Frage also
große Aufmerksamkeit geschenkt hat dass
zum Beispiel für Russland das ist
weniger relevant als für die Türkei
würde ich jetzt so sagen aber in anderen
Fragen wiederum braucht Russland die
Türkei also die für Russland sehe ich
jetzt Schwerpunkt und das ist was für
mich
so ein Take Away von heutigen Treffen
das ist die Räder von einem zweiten
Atomkraftwerk ist aber sonst zurück zu
der Frage zu dieser balanzierung kommt
entscheiden jetzt sehe ich keine also
dass die Türkei wird da weiter
manipulieren und balancieren sie haben
gerade eben den Bau des zweiten AKWs
schon angesprochen es war vorne in der
Sendung auch schon mal Thema dazu eine
user-frage meint erdogan ist ernst oder
hat er eigene Interessen wie der Bau
eines AKWs Gaslieferung aus Russland und
so weiter
ja also alles was die Türkei macht ist
im Interesse an Gras
Atomkraftwerk das oder Atomkraft Energie
das ist schon ein Thema in der Türkei
seit langem hier so seit 16 Jahren
und das ist schon eine wichtige Schritt
also das war schon der erste Bau und bei
dem zweiten gab es noch andere
Alternativen und das fand ich jetzt auch
wir merkenswert dass das so eigentlich
betont wurde von beiden Seiten so dass
tatsächlich jetzt in der Planung ist und
bei dieser Frage sprechen wir auch von
einem gesamten Industrie heute Event
25000 Mitarbeiter von beiden Seiten sind
involviert wir sprechen auch vom
Ausbildungen der Leute für diese
Industrie spricht
die
türkische Spezialisten werden in
Russland dafür ausgebildet und das ist
schon sehr wichtig und auch mehrfach hat
guten Beton diese strategische Natur in
dieser Zusammenarbeit und wenn wir auch
jetzt noch mal ganz konkret werden auch
bei dem getreidedeal darüber noch mal
sprechen warum bräuchte die Türkei
diesen Getreide-
das ist schon auch für die eigene
Wirtschaft der Türkei wichtig das ist
das erste
zweitens Türkei braucht
das Ziel dass das weiter läuft wieder
belebt wird weil andere auch sich in
acht kapazitätiert das ist das braucht
das für die ähm dafür die Unterstützung
der Staaten
drittens auch schon bei der Planung von
diesem ersten die im Juli letztes Jahr
da war die redet dass die das ankara hat
gehofft mit diesem Ziel so ein Schritt
Richtung Waffel Stillstand zu schaffen
so und auch vor kurzem hat der
Außenminister sie dann davon gesprochen
wie wichtig Stabilität im
Schwarzmeerraum ist und das ist
tatsächlich so wir gesehen solange der
Deal da war war Schwarzmeer so relativ
ruhig im Gegensatz zu jetzt wie das auch
im Beitrag erwähnt wurde bin so Angriff
auf die helfen und
dazu passt die Frage aus dem Stream von
Thomas Rabenstein er fragt sich warum
man überhaupt mit Putin verhandelt warum
fahren die Frachter nicht über
bulgarische und rumänische
Hoheitsgewässer eskortiert von
naturschiffen
weil der Weg durch schwarze Meer ist
schneller und effizienter das war schon
sofort Kriegszeiten so 90% vom so
exportform Getreide war von der Ukraine
durch schwarze Männer das ist und das
hat man auch gesehen im Vergleich zu
Solidarität
der EU geschaffen oder sie zusammen mit
der Ukraine also der mehr der Weg über
das Meer ist effizienter
und noch eine weitere Frage die sich
anschließend auf Facebook möchte wissen
was das Getreide an Abkommen an angeht
macht Putin natürlich ein Punkt im macht
Poker so schreibt der User seine Meinung
aber das Putin sich aus Russland nicht
mehr raus traut weil er Angst hat
verhaftet zu werden schwächt ihn doch in
der Außenwirkung sehr oder nicht weil
sie haben sie angesprochen erdogan ist
nach Sotschi gereist nicht so Putin ähm
außerhalb Russland gereist darauf
bezieht sich diese Frage also schwächt
Ihnen das in der Außenwirkung
die diese Tatsache dass es Erdogan war
und nicht guten würde ich schon sehen
dass Erdogan braucht dieses Getreide die
und das Treffen war auch so als
Meinungsaustausch gedacht aber natürlich
das ist jetzt in anderen Ländern
relevant und
das schwächt natürlich aber ich weiß
nicht wie sehr das für Putin wichtig ist
und dann öffnen wir noch mal schauen auf
das große Bild auf das Verhältnis
zwischen diesen beiden Ländern in den
letzten Monaten wir haben sie
angesprochen zuletzt hatten sie sich im
Oktober gesehen dazwischen gab es auch
immer mal wieder Verstimmung wo stehen
die beiden jetzt was würden Sie sagen
heute nachdem sie auch die beiden
beobachtet haben bei diesem Treffen wie
stehen die beiden jetzt einander
gegenüber
ich sehe da keine grundsätzliche
Änderungen in diesem Verhältnis
weil das also dieser Partnerschaft
bezeichne ich inzwischen also als einer
problemlos in der Partnerschaft das
heißt die haben viele Fragen die die zu
lösen versuchen und wichtig dabei ist ob
die es schaffen eine für beide Seite
vorteilhafte Lösung zu finden und es
sieht so aus dass das weiter läuft weil
die sind einfach
sehr aufeinander angewiesen in Syrien in
Syrien würde auch ich davon sprechen
dass das die Türkei Russland mehr
braucht
in Libyen das wurde auch von guten heute
erwähnt im Süd
auch im Schwarzmeer und das ist die Idee
entscheiden Unterschied wenn wir jetzt
vom Verhältnis zwischen zum Beispiel der
Türkei und so wird Union sprechen zu
Zeiten vom Kalten Krieg da gab es schon
auch bilaterale Zusammenarbeit auch
energiebeziehung hatten Ursprung in so
80er Jahren aber damals hatten wir kein
also das war es gab kein so dieses
regionales Konfliktmanagement das haben
die bei der erste geschafft neulich und
das ist was dieses Verhältnis ausmacht
also die haben einfach sehr viel
miteinander zu tun und die beste
beschreibt und ich bis jetzt getroffen
habe was das Verhältnisse so beschreibt
das ist die Aussage von einem ehemaligen
russischen Botschafter mit der 90er
Jahre hatte gesagt Russland
und die Türkei sitzen im selben Boot und
wenn das Boot sinkt dann sinken wir
beide und das ist tatsächlich so
entweder sind die in der Krise wie wir
gesehen haben über Syrien
2015/2016 oder die schaffen es
tatsächlich auf im Boot zu bleiben
sie sitzen im selben Boot aber
gleichzeitig macht die Türkei ja
trotzdem auch noch etwas und zwar dies
mit der Ukraine verkauft da also auch
Waffen hin fertige Drohnen wie
beeinflusst das aber das Verhältnis weil
da hat sich ja Russland auch schon dazu
geäußert zumindest auch zu dem hatten es
angesprochen Gefangenen Austausch da
gibt es ja tatsächlich auch etwas
zwischen den beiden steht oder nicht
ja also das sollte mir auch über diesen
Dreieck sprechen Russland die Türkei und
die Ukraine und warum das so
funktioniert weil ich meine die Ukraine
hat auch mehr erwartenden an die Türkei
und ist auch nicht glücklich über die
Beziehung die Türkei mit Russland fliegt
aber wenn wir den Verlauf sehen so sieht
man dass die Parteien die sind gesehen
dass die Zusammenarbeit mit der Türkei
einen Preis erfordert und die sind auch
bereit zu zahlen diesen Preis also z.B
russland hat macht sich keine Illusionen
dass die Türkei eigentlich in erster
Linie ein NATO Mitglied ist und
dementsprechend gibt auch
dementsprechend betrachtet auch Russland
die Türkei aber eben die unabsicht was
jetzt die Türkei so dieser unabhängige
Außenpolitik macht
da das schafft auch Russland Vorteil mit
der Türkei zu kooperieren so dass die
Türkei ist so ein Sondermittel zu Wort
für die NATO aber auch so ein sonder
Natur auch für Russland also das heißt
russisch ich denke die russische
Touren erwartet auch keine Exklusivität
seitens Ankara in diesem Verhältnis das
kann zum Beispiel auch zum Ausdruck im
Kommentaren wie diese frei diese dieser
diese fünf Kriegsgefangene zurück in
Ukraine erreichen da hat Putin sprechen
ja wir verstehen das Ankara jetzt unter
Druck steht und das war das war es gab
keine kritische Äußerungen deswegen auch
in der Ukraine
in der Ukraine ist etwas anderes als zum
Anfang des Krieges hat man tatsächlich
viel von der Türkei erwartet und hat
auch Türkei also nicht nur als freche
Partner
solltest du sowieso auch offizielle
Ebene aber eben so als alliierte
betrachtet und
durch also diese Beziehung zwischen
der Türkei und Russland da spricht man
jetzt eher ich meine auf Expertenebene
auf Präsidentschaft Ebene habe ich nie
so ein keine kritische Aussagen gehört
aber auf Experten Ebene spricht man
schon dass die Türkei sei kein
mehr sondern eine als als Vermittler ja
aber so strategisch ist schwierig mit
der Türkei zu arbeiten
dann sie sagten zwei Russland verlangt
keine Exklusivität aber vielleicht
könnten Sie uns trotzdem diese
hypothetische Frage zunächst mal aus dem
Chat beantworten von Ahmed bei Youtube
er schreibt wenn sich die Türkei am Ende
für einer Seite entscheiden muss wird
sie sich für den Westen oder für
Russland entscheiden
ähm
naja das ist ähm
dann sollen wir vielleicht betrachten
was heißt das also bei dieser Frage
würde ich jetzt auch die Konsequenzen
sehen was heißt das wenn die Türkei sich
für den besten entscheidet weil was man
gesehen hat in der Positionierung der
Türkei immer diesen Krieg in Russland
ist das
der Krieg in der Ukraine ist nicht das
wichtigste Anliegen für Ankara ist das
ist nicht das Wichtigste und auch nicht
das einzigste Problem der Türkei wenn
man so die Nachbarschaft betrachtet also
Syrien ist davon Priorität mit Irak dann
gibt's auch öffentliches Mittelmeer und
auch die super Frage und da und Ukraine
wird erst danach platziert und auch
eher als so regionale und fliegt
deswegen also in Ukraine sich nicht dass
jetzt die Türkei für den besten sich
entscheiden würde weil die Türkei in
Syrien auf Russland angewiesen ist und
das hat auch guten heute so erwähnt
Syrien eigentlich auch die Wichtigkeit
vom Astana Format und im Astana Format
ist auch Iran dabei und gestern haben
sich auch die Außenminister der Türkei
getroffen
so dass wenn ich so die regionale
eigentlich die Außenpolitik der Türkei
wird zur regional bestimmt und da muss
man so die Priorisierung Ankers ansehen
und ja ich sehe da also da musste man
schon ähm genau
entscheiden würde dann vielleicht zum
Ende lassen Sie uns noch mal in die
Zukunft schauen heute gab es keinen
Getreide Deal die beiden werden ja
natürlich weiter im Gespräch bleiben
haben viele wirtschaftliche
Verpflichtungen miteinander wie wir
gelernt haben in dieser Sendung wer
sitzt denn insgesamt am längeren Hebel
wie könnte das jetzt in der Zukunft
weitergehen eben auch in Hinblick auf so
einen Deal
das mit Getreide meinen sie ja ob das
jetzt heute wurde eventuell auch schon
früher im Gespräch dass Russland also
bereit ist eine Million
Getreide mit Hilfe von Katar über die
Türkei weiter zu schicken aber wie das
keine
alternativa ist und die Bedienungen
wurden heute auch wiederholt also die
bedienenden Russland das alle diese
Beschränkungen sollen aufgehoben werden
so wie das jetzt wenn ich heute die
Aussage betrachte jetzt schwierig aus
andererseits gab es auch heute treffen
nicht nur zwischen Delegationen sondern
auch so zwischen guten
Ergebnisse dieses Treffens werden wir
denken ich später noch sehen was weil
das ist auch nicht klar was da so
vereinbart wurde
so dass also ich traue mich nicht da so
einer Aussage zu machen zurzeit und
losgelöst vom Getreide die kann man das
sagen wer sitzt am längeren Hebel im
großen betrachtet tatsächlich wer ist
das stärker Land setzt sich öfter durch
am Ende
wenn man in einem Boot tatsächlich sieht
dass es also selbst wenn man ein Hebel
hätte ist die Frage will man das
tatsächlich nutzen weil zum Beispiel
2015/2016 was hat gelernt durch diese
Krise über Syrien dass der Abbruch der
Beziehung mit Russland viele Kosten mit
sich bringt so das
und im kriegen der Grünen wo jetzt der
Western für Russland quasi zu ist
braucht Russland immer noch so eine
Ausweg in die Welt und das ist jetzt
tatsächlich die Türkei
so sprich wenn wir jetzt weil es wurde
auch erwähnt und es bekannt dass die
Türkei sich an die Situation nicht
einschließt zum Beispiel jetzt würde
oder die Frage würde jetzt die Türkei
Luftraum für Russland schließen
annehmen nehmen wir an das macht die
Türkei dann verliert erstens die
türkische Wirtschaft weil Tourismus ist
schon sehr wichtig ist
und ich würde auch vermuten dass bleibt
auch nicht ohne Reaktion seitens
Russland dann sehen wir was in Syrien
und das ist quasi so ein Schneeball der
dann weiter rollt und der das Boot dann
sind so dass ich also hier will hat
haben die beide Seiten aber ist die
Frage will man das tatsächlich nutzen
die Einschätzung von daher ist
erzenkohof vom Zentrum für angewandte
Türkei studieren vielen Dank dafür danke
schön
der türkische Präsident zeigt sich
zumindest hoffnungsvoll auch nach dem
gescheiterten Deal heute das ist noch
etwas wären werden könnte und sagt die
UN und die Türkei hätten neue Vorschläge
zusammengestellt um die Frage zu lösen
wir dürfen also gespannt bleiben ob das
noch etwas wird für heute zunächst
einmal danke dass ihr dabei war
zugeschaut habt Fragen gestellt hat vor
allem und eben gerne bis zum nächsten
Mal bis dahin tschüss